iran's new president has pushed a
message of national unity and
reconciliation during his inauguration
speaking just after he was sworn in
ibrahim raisi also said his country's
nuclear program is peaceful
and that pressure and sanctions won't
deter the iranian people
raising faces several challenges as he
enters office
including regional tensions an economic
downturn
and the pandemic the iranian
peaceful nuclear program is peaceful
peaceful peaceful the nuclear weapons
has nothing to do with the policy and
the strategy
of iran pressures
and sanctions will never
let down the iranian people we will
defend
our right in scientific development
sanctions on the iranians should
come to an end ali hashem joins us now
live from tehran
uh ali a really wide-ranging speech from
ac
addressing economic challenges foreign
policy as well as
of course the nuclear program what were
the big takeaways for
you well prime risi
um is presenting himself positioning
himself as
as everyone expected before as a
revolutionary
president of you know iran and uh
contrary to the
pragmatic president that uh was before
him so
he used uh the the the uh
narratives of the islamic revolution of
1979 talking about the
oppressed uh saluting the jihadi groups
who were
in the in the the hall in the ceremony
and at the same time
there was something new which was
concentrating more on
regional dialogue regional security
while just giving a a slight
uh attention to the west and then
it was clear that ibrahimovic wanted to
say our priority is the region
we are ready to listen to whatever
initiatives
there are for the nuclear program but
this is not going to be our priority
this is what he
tried to say as for the internal uh side
of his speech and that was alongside it
was clear that
he wanted to show that he is in the
middle
between all trying to bring people on
his side
in this fight against what he said
corruption
trying to get the country out of the
economic crisis
trying to push with some social changes
so this is what uh ibrahim had to say
today in his
in his long speech but at the same time
he didn't present his government as it
was expected this is going to be
maybe next week as he said and uh at the
end
he uh emphasized on everything related
to the principles of the
islamic revolution and the uh supreme
leaders
directions to him and to his new
government
ali this president has been described as
ultra conservative as as being a
hardliner
and yet he talked a lot about national
reconciliation as you mentioned saying
you know our people want us to be the
voice of the poor
the voice for social freedoms what
should we read into all of that
at the beginning of his speech he said
i'm the servant of the people and
the slogan he used during this
presidential campaign was
the government of the people and this is
what he wanted to say from the beginning
that he is trying to
represent these peoples now with
extending his hand to
the other factions in the country to the
moderates to the reformists
is trying to uh maybe as of the as from
the beginning
to create a a feeling of
national unity and that's why he said
this is a government of national
consensus however the country
he needs this because the country is in
a real economic crisis the country is
facing
external challenges threats so
without having this national unity
around him and as his government
he is going to be criticized he's going
to be faced with a lot of
questions and at the same time he's not
going to be able to
go through in his plans now he has the
parliament on his side and this is what
the parliament's
speaker said at the beginning of this
ceremony he has the
judiciary and he was previously the head
of the judiciary
so his successor was telling him you are
also on your side with respect to the
uh to fighting corruption however he
needed other factions and this is why
he's right now extended his extending
his his hand to them
so that the more he can have maybe
advise the more he can have national
consensus around him
the more he can have people at least
tolerating
his government's misachievements at the
beginning
the more he can push forward because at
the end if brahim raisi by the end of
the four years was able to come out
with a positive result and end the
economic crisis this is going to be a
great achievement for him and this is
going to be
his legacy for the future all right
thank you for that update there ali
hashem live for us
in tehran